-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, yesterday,
The White House
had a press briefing,
and they announced that
they reached out to North Korea
to restart nuclear talks
but had not heard back.
At first, I thought the reason
for the lack of response
might be that Kim Jong-Un
uses a fax machine,
but then I remembered Biden
does, too, so...
Well, hours after
The White House said
it hadn't received
a response from North Korea,
Kim Jong-Un's sister
made a statement.
Listen to this.
-This new warning to
the Biden administration.
She says...
-Ooh!
-Okay!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Yeah, nice try, North Korea,
but we're America.
We haven't slept well
for the past five years, so...
Seriously,
only four years without sleep
sounds like a bargain.
Also, I like that Kim Jong-Un
had his sister deliver
the message.
It's like North Korea's
version of,
"I heard a noise in America.
Go check it out."
Oh, and here's some big news.
According to U.S. intelligence,
Russia and Iran
tried to interfere with
the 2020 election.
Biden's like, "Well, whatever
you did, thanks, fellas."
Yeah.
This is pretty rough news
for Trump.
It's like losing
in Little League
and then finding out
your dad bribed the ump.
Right now, Putin and
the ayatollah are on a couch
like a Nora Ephron movie.
[ Russian accent ]
We met hacking the election.
He wanted to hack ballots.
I wanted to hack Twitter.
And we've been together
ever since.
Well, some business news here.
I saw that Mountain Dew
is releasing
a new sugar-free soda called
Frost Bite Zero Sugar.
Here's a photo.
Yeah, something tells me that
if you're drinking
a neon-blue drink called
Frost Bite,
you're not that worried about
the sugar content.
Meanwhile, I saw that
Heinz just launched
three new
combo condiments called
Hanch, Wasabioli, and Tarchup.
-Yes!
-When asked how they came
up with these, Heinz was like,
"We got draked --
drunk and baked."
I'm actually trying to be
a little healthier,
so I'm waiting for Tarchup Zero.
That's right -- there are
three new combo condiments.
There's Tarchup, which is
tartar sauce and ketchup,
Hanch, which is
hot sauce and ranch,
and Wasabioli,
which is wasabi and aioli.
They're funny names,
but some of the other combos
they tried
didn't really work out.
For example,
they tried combining
balsamic and hot sauce
and got...
Then they combined
oil, aioli, and mayo and got...
And, finally, they combined
beef gravy, Italian dressing,
and Greek yogurt in a wok
with barbecue sauce and got...
I mean, that's...
This is interesting.
A new study found that almost
80% of Manhattan office workers
will not return to
their workplace full time
once their office reopens.
Yep, 80% are happy that they
won't return to their workplace,
while the other 20% are parents.
"I'll be back in 15 hours.
You guys know how to tuck
yourselves in, right?
Cool. See ya."
Yeah, bosses are already trying
to get people to come back.
They're like, "Come on.
There's free Hanch
in the kitchen."
It sort of makes sense.
It's basically, "Do I want
my three-bedroom office
with a private bathroom
or do I want to share a cubicle
with Frank,
the guy in the office
who burns microwave popcorn?"
[ Chuckles ]
There's someone here
that does that.
I forget who it is.
I'll find out.
I always smell it.
Is that you, Quest?
-Yeah.
-I go, "Come on, man.
If you're gonna do it,
just make -- Just stop it.
You know,
I know you'll waste 10 kernels.
Just don't --"
"I got to push all the way.
Got to get
all those kernels popped."
You ruined it, burned it, and
the whole office smells like it.
-2 minutes and 37 seconds.
I got it to a science.
-No way, man. No, no.
I'm sensor pop all the way, man.
-Sensor pop?
-Yeah, man.
You got to do it by the sensors.
You type "popcorn sensor,"
and it shuts off automatically.
-It does?
-Yeah.
-I got to try that.
-It totally works.
You know how they do it?
-How do they do it?
-What do you think? Any guesses?
-Um, I would guess that it's,
like -- It's an audio thing.
Like, it's -- Once, you know --
But you're talking
microwave oven, right?
-Correct.
-Once the microwave,
like, no longer hears
the popping sound or, you know,
once the pops are a certain,
you know, distance apart
or amount of time apart,
then it shuts down.
-Because you think it slows --
the popping slows down to --
-I know the popping slows down
as the popcorn --
That's -- Here's what we know.
[ Laughter ]
When you cook some popcorn...
-Uh-huh.
-...the closer it is
to being completely done,
the less it's gonna pop,
because, you know,
the kernels have already popped.
But there may be some strays,
you know.
-You got a couple strays there,
which totally
debunks your theory, so, no,
you're wrong, unfortunately.
-Uh, I don't know. Okay.
How's it work?
-Uh, uh...steam.
-Ah!
-There you go, everybody.
[ Laughter ]
-And now back to the show.
[ Bell dings ]
-Speaking of...
Speaking of working from home,
there's a new app
for Zoom users.
Check this out.
-The Zoom Escaper app.
It allows Zoom users
to sabotage their own calls
with sound effects,
like a crying baby.
You can also make it seem as if
you have a bad connection.
-Yeah. That's right -- an app
that will make it seem like
your Zoom has
technical difficulties.
So, basically,
these guys invented Zoom.
And, finally, some news for
Mega Millions players.
Watch this.
-An unclaimed
Mega Millions ticket
purchased last year
is set to expire tomorrow.
The winning ticket was
bought in Rhode Island
on St. Patrick's Day 2020.
It's worth $1 million,
and the rightful owner
has less than 24 hours
to accept the lump sum.
-You know last March, a guy left
the ticket in his office
next to a half-eaten sandwich,
thinking,
"I'll take care of
this tomorrow."